Ola pandoro che pandoro dulce italiano
por Navidad No però rees non ho capito
dolce molto buono e tiene una una
sorpresa Ah tipo uovo di Pasqua Tasco Io
questi non li capisco E vabbè nada nada
ciaone Oh Ma che è sta coda infinita
regalano qualcosa Perdona che
Eset della lotteria de navit lotteria
latteria ammazza se gli piace il latte
agli spagnoli Oh che devo devi mangiare
una uva
campanada e quante so Ste campan quantos
12 campanas mi devo magnare 12 acini
d'uva a ogni rintocco Ma questi so pazzi
mi soffoco se faccio una roba del genere
se tu riesci a mangiare tutte 12 ogni
rintocco te dà Buona fortuna par l'anno
che viene Sen no Senti dammi un po' Ste
uvas va Che sfiga Gi abbastanza